سافرت هذه المره الى بطره جايه المنطقه
التي تسعى لتعويضكور عاصمه لماليزيا بناها
لذلك الغرض اشهر رؤساء حكومات البلاد
واكثر زعماء العالم حكما وعمرا مهاتير
محمد سافرنا لهذه المدينه لالتقيه بعد ان
اعلن تقاعده النهائي هذه المره من السياسه
والتفرع لمذكراته لا شك ان لديه الكثير
الكثير ليتقاسمه مع العالم انا منتهى
الرمحي وهذا البعد الاخر واحييكم دائما من
العربيه
[موسيقى]
عندما قال مهاتير محمد مرتين انه يريد
الحصول على لقب العام حتى الموت فانه لم
يكن يمزح هو اخر من يمثل جيل الحرس القديم
جنوب شرق اسيا الذي اصبح تحت قيادتهم يعرف
باسم اقتصادات النمور من رفاقه توفي
سوهرتو الاندونيسي في عام 2008 ثم
السنغافوري ليكوان يوفي عام 2015 اما هو
فعل مشارف الثامنه والتسعين من العمر عاد
في نوفمبر الماضي للسباق الانتخابي كرئيسا
لتحالف ماليزي جديد شغل مهاتير محمد منصب
رئيس الوزراء لاول مره لمده 22 عاما من
عام
1981 الى عام 2003 وينسب اليه الفضل في
التطور السريع الذي شهدته ماليزيا في عام
2018 قطع تقاعده
وبمساعده مساعده السابق ثم منافسه السابق
انور ابراهيم عاد لرئاسه الوزراء لكن
التحالف فشل في تحمل ثقل الخصومات
الداخليه في فبراير من 2020 وجد مهاتير
نفسه مطروضا بعد انهيار تحالفه وفي 20 22
نفسا بحزب جديد اسسه على عقيده تناقض
تماما ما عرف عنه لكنه تكبد خساره اجبرته
هذه المره على التقاعد النهائي
وتتعارض تماما مع عرسه العريق والمختلط
والذي يجعل منه الاسم الذي سيطر على
ماليزيا مستقله
في حوار معه تحدث عن هذا الارث وهل ان
رؤيته ما زالت صالحه وتحدث عن فلسطين
واسرائيل وعن فشل فكره تاسيس منظمه موازيه
لمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي وعن استضافه
المشتبه بهم العرب وعن العولمه والغرب
المعادي للشرق ولروسيا وعن الامم المتحده
التي يجعلها حق النقد عاجزه وغير عادله
نرحب بضيفنا الدكتور مهاتير محمد رئيس
الوزراء الماليزي السابق اهلا بكم معنا
دكتور مهاتير
اسمع لي ان ابدا بالسؤال عن بعد العوده
للحياه السياسيه بعد التقاعد هل ندمت
لا كان امامي الكثير من العمل لست نادمه
بالرغم من النتيجه السيئه التي تحققت في
الانتخابات
التي اعقبت عودتي كما فزت برئاسه الوزراء
حتى في الانتخابات الاخيره انا اقصد اخر
انتخابات التي بعد انقسام الحزب التي
حصلتم فيها في البرلمان نسبه تقريبا صفر
من النتائج
نعم اعرف كان ذلك بسبب ان هذه الانتخابات
اجريت قبل ان يستكمل الحزب كل عمليه
التسجيل لذلك لم يكن باستطاعتنا المنافسه
بكيفيه ملائمه وخسرنا كل المقاعد التي
نفسنا عليها
كنت زعيم الحزب الذي سيطر على ماليزيا
لعقود من الزمن الحقيقه
البعض في تلك الفتره اتهم حزبك او اتهمك
شخصيا بالاستبداد في التعامل مع المعارضين
ما مدى صحه هذا الكلام
ولا حيوان حسنا فزت بكل الانتخابات التي
خطها خلال شغلية منصب رئيس الوزراء في
الفتره الاولى ثم في الفتره الثانيه من
شغل منصب رئيس الوزراء فزت بالانتخابات
الاولى ثم خسرت الثانيه بعد ان تمت اطاحه
من الحكومه التي شكلتها احزاب المعارضه
لماذا اصريت دكتور مهاتير على تشكيل حزب
مؤخرا تشكيل حزب
الملويه هي المسيطره عليه لماذا لم حزبا
متعدد الاعراق
كان ذلك بسبب ان الملاوي سكان ماليزيا
الاصليين اصبحوا فقراء جدا مقارنه
بالاعراق الاخرى لذلك كان يتعين ان يتم
تمثيلهم بحزب مالاوي يمثل عرقيتهم فقط
ويهتموا ببرامجهم
الا يعتبر هذا التغير في سياستك
بشكل مختلف عن المرحله الاولى التي حكمت
فيها ماليزيا
لم يكن ضميرا مني وانما لم يكن التحالف
المشكل من الاحزاب قويا بمثل ما كان عليه
خلال فتره حكم الاولى
جميعا الفتره الاولى التي تم انتخابك فيها
رئيسا للوزراء الفتره اللي قضيت فيها 22
عاما
تقريبا
استطعت فيها دكتور مهاتير ان تحول ماليزيا
من حقل الكبير للمطاط من دوله زراعيه الى
واحده من اهم الدول الاسيويه اقتصاديا
ممكن تعطينا الوصفه
كيف الطريقه ما هي الطريقه التي تعاملت
بها حتى نجحت بكل هذه السنوات
لا انفسه في الفتره الاولى التي اصبحت
فيها رئيس وزراء كان حزبي قويا جدا كانت
له سلطه تامه على البرلمان كنت قادرا بسبب
ذلك على القيام بامور كثيره من ضمنها
تحويل ماليزيا من دوله زراعيه الى دوله
صناعيه
لكن وكانه القرار كان قرارا سياسيا فقط
انا اريد ان توضح لي اكثر كيف نجحت في
ماليزيا لواحده من اكبر اقتصادات اسيا ان
تتحول من دوله زراعيه الى واحده من اكبر
اقتصادات اسيا الوصفه الطريقه
مين
اساسا بسبب قوه الحكومه التي كانت تسندها
اغلبيه مريحه لذلك كنا قادرين على اتخاذ
القرارات وكان البرلمان يمنحها الدعم
الكامل وبسبب ان الناس في ماليزيا كانوا
بحاجه الى العمل وهو ما لا يتوفر بما يكفي
في دوله تعتمد على الزراعه ولذلك قررنا
اطلاق الصناعات لان ذلك يسمح للكثيرين
بالعمل وهو ما وفر الدعم لسياستنا من قبل
الناس لانهم يستفيدون من تحويل البلاد من
دوله زراعيه الى دوله صناعيه
تتصور بانه هذه الوصفه صالحه او ما زالت
صالحه لماليزيا او لاي دوله اخرى ان يكون
هناك اتفاق سياسي على تطوير المجتمع
نعم ما زلت صالحه غالبيه الدول التي تعتمد
على الزراعه لا يمكنها ان تصبح ثريه لو
تتجه نحو الصناعه فانها ستوفر الكثير من
الفرص والعمل والوظائف لشعوبها التي ستصبح
اثرى ولذلك نرى دائما ان تدور الصناعيه
اكثر ثراء من الدول الزراعيه رجالا
في عام 2018
وايضا في انتخابات 2022
حضرتك اكدت انه اولوياتك محاربه الفساد
واستعاده سياده القانون وضمان حريه
التعبير وقلت ان ماليزيا
تحولت لمجرد واجهه ديمقراطيه وليست
ديمقراطيه حقيقيه
البعض اعتبر انه هذا اعتراف
بفشل افكارك طوال الفتره التي حكمت بها هل
هذا صحيح او كيف تقرا هذا الاعتبار يا
كرسيا دوله ديمقراطيه فقط من حيث ان شعبها
قادر على تغيير الحكومات بواسطه الحكومات
لكن الديمقراطيه تتطلب ايضا حريه التعبير
وحريه الصحافه وايضا صياده القانون كل هذه
الامور تاتي جميعا مع الديمقراطيه غير
اننا ورغم اننا ننتخب حكومتنا فاننا من
ناحيه حريه التعبير ما زلنا في الخلف
لاننا دوله متعدده الاعراق ومن المهم ان
لا تتقاتل هذه الاعراق
ما الذي يعنيه هذا بالتحديد هل يمكن ان
نقول عمليه دوله ديمقراطيه ام انها ما
زالت غير ديمقراطيه مئه بالمئه
نعم لكن ديمقراطيه تترجم باشكال مختلفه
عبر مختلف الدول في ماليزيا وبسبب ان
لدينا دوله متعدده الاعراق فان الاوكد
والاهم الا تكون لنا خلافات او اشتباكات
او صراع بين مختلف مكونات المجتمع ولذلك
فان كل ما من شانه ان يدفع الاعراق على
التقاتل غير مسموح به ولذلك فانه في الوقت
الذي لديك كامل الحريه فانه ينبغي ان تكون
لك الحريه في تحديد سرعه تلك دقيقه كلما
استدعى الامر ولذلك فان ماليزيا هي
ديمقراطيه غير ليبراليه
يا دكتور
البعض يعتقد بان مجرد الذهاب لصندوق
الاقتراع يعتبر ديمقراطيه او تعتبر ممارسه
للديمقراطيه
هناك عده اشكال للديمقراطيه لا يوجد شكل
محدد معياري هناك ثقافات وعادات وظروف
ينبغي اخذها بعين الاعتبار مثلا في
بريطانيا هناك ملك ولكنه لا يتمتع
بالسلطات تنفيذيه لقد اتبعنا هذا النظام
نكون في امريكا حتى رئيس السلطه الحكوميه
يجري انتخابه من قبل الشعب لذلك فانهم
ليبراليون اكثر ومع ذلك في امريكا نفسها
هناك الكثير من الميز العنصري خاصه ضد
السود لذلك فانه حتى امريكا لا يصح ان
نطلق عليها صفه
الديمقراطيه كامله
دكتور مهاتير هل يمكن لكل دوله ان تختار
شكل الديمقراطيه التي يناسبها هل هناك
تعريف عام
للديمقراطيه يمكن ان ينطبق على كل دول
العالم
عندما تكون لك ديمقراطيه فان من شروطها ان
تكون الحكومه منتخبه من الشعب لكن الامور
الاخرى يمكن تعديلها وفقا للظروف الاخرى
ما الذي تريد ان يتذكرك به الناس
حقا لا يعني الامر اي شيء بنسبه اليه
السواء تذكرني الناس ام لا هذا هو موقفي
حقه لا يهمني ما اذا تذكر الناس ارثي او
امتدحوه اولى
دعني اذهب معك باتجاه اخر في الحوار
السياسه نفسها التي انتقدت ماليزيا من
اجلها في بدايه القرن تكررت في السنوات
الاخيره البعض يعتقد بانه ماليزيا اصبحت
ملاذا
لجماعات غير مرغوب فيها بها في بعض الدول
جماعات متطرفه بشكل او باخر بالذات في
الدول العربيه اصبح مقرها ماليزيا هل هذا
صحيح ما مدى دقه هذا الكلام
متطرفه او متشدده في ماليزيا نعم ولكن اي
اشخاص او اطراف بانشطه عنيفه مثل
التفجيرات والعمليات الانتحاريه هذا لم
يحدث في ماليزيا وفي بلدنا لدينا خلافات
ومع ذلك نحن لا يقاتل بعضنا البعض بدون
صحيح ولكن هل استقبلت ماليزيا اي من
المتطرفين
المرفوضين من الدول العربيه هل كان في
تواصل ما بين ماليزيا وتركيا من اجل
استقبال هؤلاء مثلا
وخلينا نحكي بصراحه عن عن من هم تابعين
لتيار الاخوان في نهايه الامر
حسنا ماليزيا دوله منفتحه جدا وكل شخص
يمكنه القدوم الى هنا والبقاء لفتره طويله
ونحن دوله لها نظامها الخاص في سياسه
الدخول وغالبيه الجنسيات لا تحتاج تاشيره
دخول لدينا عدد كبير من الجنسيات التي
تعيش بيننا ولا يمكننا ان نحدد بني
الارهابي او مشروع ارهابي او متطرف من
بينهم في بعض الاحيان ربما هناك ما يقيم
في ماليزيا ولكن كانت له اعمال عنيفه في
دول اخرى اما فيما يتعلق بتركيا فحتى الان
لدينا علاقه جيده معها سوفا
نعم ولكن هل هناك في ماليزيا اي من
المطلوبين سواء للدول العربيه كمصر مثلا
او لي اي دوله اخرى من من
هم متهمون بالتطرف والارهاب هؤلاء ليسوا
مواطنين عاديين بالتاكيد اسمائهم لازم
تكون معروفه لدى الدوله الماليزيه
نعم ولكن لو يتم تمكيننا من ادله ومعلومات
تثبت انهم ارهابيون فساعتها يمكننا اتخاذ
اجراءات او يمكننا طردوهم من اراضينا ولا
يمكننا بالضروره ارسالهم الى دوالهم هكذا
من دون اي معلومات مثبته
بحجه ماذا يعني لماذا لا يتم تسليمهم
لدولهم اذا كانوا متهمين بالارهاب
شمبان كانتري في بعض الاحيان في بعض دول
هؤلاء هم لا يلقون محاكمات عادله وهذا
يفرض وعلينا مسؤوليه قانونيه واخلاقيه
ولذلك اذا رغبت اي دوله في الحصول عليهم
فعليها ان تبحث عنهم في دول اخرى غير
ماليزيا
ومشاهدينا الكرام نذهب الى فاصل قصير نعود
بعده لمتابعه هذا الحوار في البعد الاخر
مع الدكتور مهاتير محمد
ارحب بكم معنا من جديد من ماليزيا وضيفنا
في هذه الحلقه من البعد الاخر الدكتور
مهاتير محمد اهلا وسهلا بك معنا من جديد
دكتور مهدي ماليزيا
وانت تحديدا
من منظمه التعاون الاسلامي بتشكيل تجمع
اخر مختلف قاطعه منظمه التعاون الاسلامي
وقاطعته الدول العربيه اكبر الحضور فيه
كان من الاخوان المسلمين 150 شخصيه تقريبا
ماذا اردتم من هذا التجمع
ليس صحيحا اننا انسحبنا او غادرنا منظمه
التعاون الاسلامي ما زلنا اعضاء فيها لكن
هذه المنظمه تضم اكثر من 50 دوله وراينا
ان قانونها المنظم يجعلها غير قادره على
العمل بسبب الخلافات على اتخاذ القرارات
لذلك في العثور على دول يمكنها الاتفاق
وتعمل بنفس نظامنا لقد رغبت الدول الخمس
في اظهار انه بامكان المسلمين ان يقوموا
هم ايضا بعمل جيد واذا نجحنا فان ذلك
سيكون مثالا للدول المسلمه الاخرى
نجحتم في ذلك عن فوتنا للاسف لم ننجح في
خطتنا بسبب انه خلال اجتماعاتنا
بصعوبات كما ان عده دول عربيه اعترضت ما
ادى لعدم مشاركه دول مثل باكستان
واندونيسيا الكبيرهتين لكن الاجتماع كان
جيدا من حيث انه كان بنيه تقديم اقتراح
لمصلحه كل الدول الاسلاميه لكن فشل حيث لم
يكن هناك تنفيذ لما تقرر خلال الاجتماع
وكانك تقول دكتور مهاتير بانه اندونيسيا
وباكستان قرارهم ليس بيدهم قررهم منوط بجه
اخرى منعتهم من الحضور لماذا لا يكون قرار
باكستان واندونيسيا انه ما تشارك بحاله
الانقسام هذه التي يعني
تاسست لها ماليزيا
ذهب لقد نجح العربيه في اقناع باكستان
واندونيسيا بعدم الالتفات للفكره ونحن لم
يكن لدينا نفس الوزن او القوه لمجابهه اي
طرف راغبنا فقط بان نعقد مؤتمرا بكيفيه
هادئه فقط لكل من كانت قادرا على الحضور
ومن لم يرغب في الحضور في الامر كان يعود
له وقد ناقش الامر مع الدول العربيه
الرافضه لعقد مؤتمر كوالالمبورت
بس لحد هلا احنا مش فاهمين او لا نستطيع
ان نفهم
ما الهدف من عقد هذا المؤتمر او هذا
الملتقى
لقد رغبنا في اظهار ان دول المسلمين
بامكانها ان تكون متقدمه وان تقدم مثال
جيده للحوكمه فبخمسين دوله لم يكن الاتفاق
سهلا على التوصل للاسلوب الملائم لكن بخمس
دول فقط كان يمكن تقديم الطريق لذلك ثم
توسيعه في حال النجاح بحيث تتبعه الدول
الاخرى
ايران نموذج كانت موجوده ايران هل تحكم
ايران بطريقه طبيعيه انت ترى يحصل في
ايران الان
نووي نحن لم نناقش ايران ناقشنا فقط مثال
الحوكمه الجيد كنا نرغب باظهار الطريق
للاخرين ولم نجبر احدا اذا رغبوا
بالالتحاق يمكنهم ذلك واذا لم يرغبوا
فالامر عائد لهم انا بدي اخذ رايك
[موسيقى]
دكتور مهاتير بما يحصل الان في اوكرانيا
بين روسيا والدول الغربيه اعطيني تقييمك
نعم كما تعلمون فان روسيا فككت الاتحاد
السوفيتي وعده دول منحت حريتها بسبب ذلك
ومنها وكلها كانت جزءا من الفيدراليه
الروسيه لكن ما حدث لاحقا ان بعض تلك
الدول عندما امتلكت حريتها رغبت بالانضمام
الى النيتو المعارض لروسيا وبالطبع تشعر
روسيا بان ذلك خطر يهددها حيث ان عده دول
صافيه سابقه كانت تابعه لفدراليه روسيا
اصبحت اعضاء في التجمع الغربي هذا التجمع
الغربي واداه النيتو تم احداثه لمجابهه
روسيا واعتبارها عدوه لو كانت هذه الدول
بعيده عن روسيا اعتقد ان موسكو ما كانت
لتقوم باي شيء ولكن بحكم محاذاه اوكرانيا
لروسيا وعندما تنضم اوكرانيا للنيتو فان
الخطر يصبح وجوديا على موسكو لان العدو
اصبح على الحدود المباشره ما يجعلها تشعر
بانها غير امنه لان العدو قريب جدا
انمي
اذا مخاوف روسيا
[موسيقى]
هناك
الكثير من المواطنين حول العالم متشائمون
في 20 23
حسنا لقد اصبح العالم مفتوحا اكثر واصبح
من السهل الوصول لكل مناطقه اضافه الى
السهوله التي اصبح عليها التنقل
والاتصالات كان يفترض بسبب ذلك ان تعمل كل
دول العالم جنبا الى جنب لكننا الان دار
العكس ترى تعارضا بين الغرب والشرق بين
امريكا وروسيا والصين انهم يركزون الان
على الاستعداد للحرب لدينا الامم المتحده
لكنها تحت ضغط والسيطره خمس دول لها حق
الفيتو ولا يمكننا الاعتراض علامه تقرره
هناك بسبب سلطه النقد دائما ما تعترض هذه
الدول على ما ترغب بالقيام به حتى لو كان
جيدا للعالم اجمع
هل يمكن تغيير هذه المعادله معادله خمس
دول التي لها حق الفيتو ومن الذي يستطيع
ان يغيرها وقال بيشون بيشون حسنا يتعين
علينا ذلك يحصل بنا ان نلغي سلطه الفيتو
لانها تتعارض مع الديمقراطيه فدوله
بمفردها يمكنها تعطيل اكثر من 190 دوله
دفعه واحده هذا كل ما يعنيه الفيتو لذلك
هو غير ديمقراطي ينبغي ان نتخلص منه ومن
هذا النظام غير الديمقراطي ونستبدله بنظام
ديمقراطي يمكن الجمعيه العموميه من ان
تكون لها سلطه التقرير عبر تصويت تتخذ فيه
الغالبيه القرار لكن الان حتى لو اتخذت
[موسيقى]
هل العولمه يعني نراها اكثر مطبقه في
السياق الثقافي الاجتماعي عن التجاري
ندرس ريال ربع
الطول ذات لا توجد عولمه حقيقيه ما نراه
لها من معنى الان هو انه يتعين الابقاء
على الصين وروسيا عدوين اذا كان هناك منطق
عدو فان ذلك يفرغ هذه العباره بالمعناها
لانه يقسم العالم الى جزئين شرق وغرب
يتصارعان دومه
وتدفعهما الرغبه لاختراق الزمات والتوترات
اخر الامثله عن ذلك عندما زارت رئيسه مجلس
النواب الامريكيه السابقه التايوان حتى
قبل ان يتخذ الامر بين الصين والتايوان
صبغه التوتر الحقيقي او حتى قبل ان تظهر
بوادر اشتباك
ودفعت زياره هذه السيده لتايوان الصين
لموقف قوي وعد اي تجاه تايوان التي تجد
نفسها الان في وضع دفاعي صعب فالاستفزاز
به الولايات المتحده لكونها تعرف ان
تايوان ستكون بحاجه للسلاح الذي تحصل
واشنطن من تجارته على اموال كثيره انا
الدكتور
دائما للقضيه الفلسطينيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه ضاعت في اروقه الامم المتحده
ام ضاعت بسبب سياسات داخليه ام ماذا
ما هو المخرج
فلسطين
لم يربح الفلسطينيون قضيتهم بسبب دعم
الولايات المتحده لاسرائيل فالولايات
المتحده دوله قويه جدا ولذلك يمكن
للاسرائيل ان تقوم باي شيء بما في ذلك خرق
القانون الدولي وامريكا تدعمها وتدافع
عنها في مجلس الامن وعسكريه لذلك وبهذا
الوضع لا يمكن حل القضيه الفلسطينيه حلها
لا يمكن ان يتم
في حال خضوعوع الجميع للقانون وفي حال
التوقف دعم واشنطن لاسرائيل والذي نراه
يتكرر حتى في حال خرق اسرائيل للقانون
هل ترى انه في امل بمفاوضات بين الجانبين
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني ممكن ان تصل الى حد
يا سيد
هو في اجتماع الطرفين فقط اي الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي على مائده الحوار من دون ان
يتقاتل هذا هو الاسلوب الامثل
في نهايه لقائنا في البعد الاخر اود ان
اشكرك جزيل الشكر دكتور مهاتير محمد على
المشاركه معنا الف شكر لك وبهذا انتهت هذه
الحلقه من البعد الاخر وكالعاده يمكنكم
دائما متابعه برنامجنا على تويتر فيسبوك
ويوتيوب كما يمكنكم الاستماع الى هذه
الحلقه على العربيه بودكاست الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]